Trascrizione: Claudia Di Lorenzo
Revisore: Isabelle Andrieu
(Musica)
Che cosa accadrebbe,
se domani mattina vi svegliaste
in un mondo senza musica?
Vi perdereste sicuramente
qualcosa di bello,
qualcosa che vi piace,
ma sarebbe semplicemente rinunciare
a qualcosa che vi piace
come mangiare la pizza il sabato sera,
o andreste incontro
ad un cambio molto più profondo?
La musica è ovunque,
la ritroviamo in tutte le culture,
in ogni angolo del mondo,
perché è quello che ci permette
di connettere gli uni con gli altro.
È un collante relazionale,
basti pensare a quello che succede
normalmente nei concerti,
ed è la colonna sonora
delle nostre giornate, dei nostri eventi.
La musica sembra proprio qualcosa
che ci portiamo dietro da sempre.
L'oggetto un po' strano
che vedete alle mie spalle
è un reperto archeologico
e più precisamente si tratta di un osso.
È l'osso di un orso delle caverne
risalente a circa 55.000 anni fa.
Cosa c'entra?
C'entra perché alcuni studiosi
si sono concentrati su questo osso,
proprio su quei fori,
e hanno provato a ricostruirlo,
formulando un'ipotesi
che per noi oggi è molto più attraente.
Infatti potrebbe trattarsi
dello strumento musicale
più antico della storia,
quello che poi è stato soprannominato
il "Flauto di Neanderthal".
Accade spesso che quello che ritroviamo
fin dai primi passi
della nostra evoluzione
come esseri umani,
in realtà lo troviamo anche
nei primi passi della nostra evoluzione
come singoli individui,
cioè della nostra vita.
E sono proprio degli studi di neuroscienze
ad indicarci che noi nasciamo già
come essere musicali,
infatti il nostro cervello
quando siamo neonati,
prime ore di vita,
riesce a rispondere
specificatamente alla musica,
alla struttura musicale,
alla melodia, al ritmo,
alle differenti sfumature
emotive della musica.
In effetti la presenza
della musica nella nostra vita
sembra avere a che fare
proprio con il nostro cervello,
e in particolare con dei cambiamenti
che avvengono nei suoi circuiti
più antichi a livello evolutivo,
cioè quelli più profondi,
anche a livello anatomico.
A giocare un ruolo chiave,
qui, è una sostanza
che è cruciale per la regolazione
del nostro comportamento, tutti i giorni.
Questa sostanza è la dopamina.
La dopamina è un neurotrasmettitore
che noi di solito liberiamo
proprio nelle aree più antiche
e profonde del nostro cervello
in risposta a stimoli
come il cibo o il sesso.
Sono stimoli che ci attraggono,
che ci danno piacere,
che ci motivano, che ci danno ricompensa,
e che sono anche in qualche modo
legati alla nostra sopravvivenza.
Quello che però
abbiamo recentemente scoperto
è che in realtà la dopamina
viene anche liberata
anche in risposta alla musica.
Allora vediamo un po' quanti di voi
almeno una volta nella vita,
ascoltando una canzone, un brano musicale,
hanno provato questa sensazione qui.
Ad occhio direi un 90% abbondante.
Questi sono brividi, pelle d'oca,
sono risposte del nostro corpo
fisiologiche, o psicofisiologiche,
che possiamo associare al piacere intenso.
In una parte delle mie ricerche
io mi sono focalizzata proprio
su questo tipo di fenomeni
abbordandoli però
in un modo un po' particolare.
Infatti, con dei colleghi
di Barcellona e di Montreal,
siamo andati ad attivare o disattivare
direttamente nel cervello
quelli che pensavamo potessero essere
i meccanismi alla base di questi fenomeni,
e in particolare proprio
la liberazione di dopamina.
L'abbiamo fatto grazie
ad uno studio farmacologico
che ci ha permesso di andare ad aumentare
o diminuire temporaneamente,
quindi non vi preoccupate,
la liberazione di dopamina
nel cervello delle persone
e l'abbiamo fatto mentre le persone,
mentre i nostri partecipanti
ascoltavano musica.
La musica poteva essere
la loro musica preferita
o della musica pop-rock
che avevamo scelto noi,
quella che normalmente passa in radio.
Quello che abbiamo trovato
è che quando la dopamina aumentava
rispetto a quando diminuiva,
aumentavano anche
le loro risposte di piacere.
Cioè i partecipanti ci dicevano
di amare di più un certo brano musicale
e avevano anche più risposte
fisiologiche associate:
i brividi, la pelle d'oca.
Non solo, quando aumentava la dopamina,
aumentavano anche quelle risposte
che noi chiamiamo motivazionali.
In questo caso i partecipanti
erano disposti a pagare di più
per ottenere il brano
che stavano ascoltando.
Cioè erano disposti a dare dei soldi
per avere quel brano,
quella musica nella loro vita.
Quindi il piacere, la motivazione
legati alla liberazione di dopamina
sono fondamentali quando
cerchiamo di capire il ruolo della musica
nella nostra vita, o quantomeno
perché è nella nostra vita.
Rimane però aperta
una domanda fondamentale, cioè:
tutto questo piacere così avvolgente,
così intenso che cambia
le nostre giornate in positivo
è fine a sé stesso?
Cioè, qual è veramente
il ruolo della musica nella nostra vita?
Per provare a rispondere
vi propongo di continuare insieme
un viaggio nelle attivazioni celebrali
e vi chiedo, per quanto possibile,
di provare ad immaginare
di essere qui da soli,
mettervi le vostre cuffie,
i vostri auricolari
e cominciare ad ascoltare
una delle vostre canzoni preferite.
Quello che accadrà,
è che il vostro cervello
comincerà ad accendersi,
creando una vera e propria
costellazione di attivazioni
che riguardano aree che si attivano
e che regolano le nostre emozioni,
il nostro comportamento,
ma anche altre aree che sono implicate
nella percezione, nel movimento,
nel linguaggio, nella memoria.
La musica crea una vera e propria
sinfonia neurale nel nostro cervello.
Lo attiva e lo modula interamente.
E così facendo è capace di modularne
l'anatomia e la funzionalità.
Allora adesso possiamo fare
un passaggio fondamentale.
Visto che la maggior parte
di questi substrati neurali,
la maggior parte di queste aree
che la musica attiva
in realtà sono aree
che noi attiviamo tutti i giorni
per compiere tantissime altre attività:
sentire, leggere, parlare, camminare.
Allora possiamo cominciare a pensare
di usare la musica
per stimolare queste altre regioni
e quindi queste altre funzioni quotidiane.
È quello che ad oggi hanno fatto
moltissimi studi di psicologia,
di neuroscienze.
Ad esempio gli studi
che si sono interessati
alla capacità della musica
di stimolare delle aree
implicate nel movimento
e come questa possa essere utilizzata
in caso di deficit di movimento,
come nella malattia di Parkinson.
O ancora gli studi che si sono focalizzati
sul rapporto strettissimo
che c'è tra la musica e il linguaggio:
la musica è un vero e proprio
linguaggio universale
e possiamo utilizzare questo rapporto
ad esempio per migliorare le capacità
di lettura in bambini dislessici.
Di ricerca se n'è fatta tanta
e come spesso accade
nella ricerca scientifica
tanto ne rimane da fare e da supportare.
Io oggi vorrei parlarvi
di una fetta di questa ricerca.
È qualcosa che mi interessa
particolarmente,
ma che in realtà ci tocca
tutti nel profondo,
perché si tratta del rapporto che esiste
tra la musica e la nostra memoria.
Prima però lasciate che si attivi
un po' nel vostro cervello
quella sinfonia neurale
grazie alle note che vi farà Andrea.
[Musica e memoria]
(Musica)
La musica ha un fortissimo -
(Applausi)
Ovviamente questa presentazione
non avrebbe lo stesso valore
senza tutto questo.
So che è un valore aggiunto.
La musica ha un fortissimo
potere evocativo,
cioè un brano musicale
ha il potere letterale
di farci viaggiare nel tempo,
perché grazie ad un brano musicale
noi possiamo recuperare sensazioni,
esperienze, persone,
emozioni che associamo a quel brano.
Magari quello che vi è successo adesso
con questa versione di Bohemian Rapsody.
A giudicare dall'applauso direi di sì.
Perché sicuramente
vi è suonata famigliare.
Altri l'hanno riconosciuta.
I fan, fin da subito, dalle prime note,
e altri ci hanno messo un po' di più.
Insieme al riconoscimento,
è arrivato il ricordo
delle parole associate, per alcuni,
e altri sono andati oltre
e sono riusciti
ad associare a questo brano
dei ricordi della propria vita.
Noi questo potere evocativo della musica
l'abbiamo preso e portato in laboratorio
con il fine di capire
quali fossero i meccanismi alla base
e capire quindi un po' di più
che cosa ci fosse dietro.
Abbiamo condotto vari studi
su persone giovani,
su persone anziane,
in cui chiedevamo di memorizzare
delle informazioni con o senza musica,
e nel frattempo però monitoravamo anche
la loro attività celebrarle.
Quello che abbiamo scoperto
è che la musica può veramente aiutarci
a ricordare meglio le informazioni
e nel farlo, cioè mentre aiuta
i nostri processi di memoria,
modula il nostro cervello.
Andando a modulare quelle aree
che sì sappiamo essere importanti
per memorizzare, mantenere,
recuperare un'informazione,
ma anche aree che sono implicate
nella regolazione delle nostre emozioni
e quindi del nostro piacere.
Eccole che le ritroviamo,
le nostre risposte di piacere.
Qui non sono fine a sé stesse,
diventano rilevanti,
diventano fondamentali,
perché quello che abbiamo scoperto
è che più siamo in grado di attivare
le nostre risposte di piacere,
di ricompensa, di motivazione
in risposta alla musica,
più brividi abbiamo,
più queste risposte potranno attivare
delle regioni che sono importanti
nella formazione dei nostri ricordi
e quindi maggiori saranno i benefici
della musica sulla nostra memoria.
Questo ovviamente ha
delle implicazioni importantissime,
soprattutto se pensiamo
ai casi di deficit di memoria,
alla nostra società,
che va incontro ad un incremento
dell'invecchiamento,
sia normale sia patologico.
Durante le mie ricerche
ho avuto l'opportunità grandissima
di vedere dei pazienti Alzheimer
che erano completamenti spenti
dalla malattia,
essere in grado di riconoscere
un brano del loro passato
e anche solo per un secondo
uscire da quell'apatia.
La musica attraverso le emozioni
in queste persone riesce a far riaffiorare
dei ricordi autobiografici,
cioè dei ricordi della loro vita
che proprio a causa della malattia
sembravano persi fino all'istante prima.
E in alcuni casi
riesce anche a facilitare l'apprendimento
di nuove informazioni.
Questo tipo di ricerche ci fa capire
un po' di più come funzioniamo,
come funziona il nostro cervello,
che è il nostro organo più complesso
e forse più affascinante.
E io credo che ci insegnino
anche qualcosa.
In questo caso ci insegnano
che le nostre risposte emozionali,
emotive, quelle di piacere,
quelle che consideriamo più istintive,
arcaiche, basse, irrazionali,
in realtà le possiamo prendere
e le possiamo utilizzare
per andare a modulare,
migliorare, stimolare
delle funzioni cognitive
che invece consideriamo alte, complesse,
come l'apprendimento e la memoria.
Tutti gli studi di neuroscienze e musica
vanno nella stessa direzione
nel sottolineare l'importanza
della musica nella nostra vita.
E nella vita significa
nella nostra società.
Non solo nelle nostre case,
nelle nostre cuffie,
ma anche in ambito educativo,
quando muoviamo
i primi passi nella società,
e in abito clinico
quando invece abbiamo
delle difficoltà sul nostro percorso.
La musica è uno strumento potente,
ma questa potenza non è invasiva,
è a basso costo, e non solo può,
ma deve essere accessibile a tutti.
Quindi riempiamo la nostra vita di musica,
diamo la possibilità al nostro cervello
di cambiare e trasformarsi nel profondo
e di farlo per tutto l'arco
della nostra esistenza.
Diamogli la possibilità di un cambiamento
che è fondamentale per il nostro
funzionamento cognitivo.
Ascoltiamo musica, facciamo musica,
non ci perdiamo neanche
un secondo di quel piacere,
di quei brividi che ci può dare.
Liberiamo tutta la dopamina possibile.
Attenzione però, scegliamola bene
la musica che ascoltiamo oggi,
perché potrebbe essere proprio quella
a riattivarci domani.
Grazie.
(Applausi)